this is about a fashion brand based in
New York City they're facing a backlash
over hoodies had unveiled during New
York Fashion Week last week so they were
you know I know this is a TV medium but
we're not even going to show you the
sweatshirts I'm only showing it because
I'm so disturbed by what the company's
doing so they featured the names of
schools where mass shootings have
occurred including Stoneman Douglas
Columbine Sandy Hook and the hoodies
appear to have holes made by bullets now
they met they said listen it's a fashion
thing they did it for Fashion Week but
now they're considering selling them so
they're getting they're getting swamped
with criticism and I'm hoping that
stories like this will persuade them not
to sell them and if they do sell them
that people won't buy them well I just
think of the pain that it causes for
people and it's not it's not fashionable
it doesn't send any message they said
they're trying to bring attention to the
shootings there has to be another way to
do that criticism because I would think
that there would be a bump in attention
and attention would be good since gun
control and school shootings are such
big issues today yeah that's one way to
look at but I just think that you know
this one family from Sandy Hook said
you'll never know what our family went
through our pain is not to be used for
your fashion yeah so I get the message
well I don't even get the message if
they're trying to do I just think the
pain the the negative far outweighs a
positive better way yeah there is a
better way